so I'm gonna start with a question
why haven't offline first apps taken off
the big problem with the web is that it
does not work offline and even if you
are online if you are on a slow internet
connection your app feels terrible that
sucks
take a step back that seems like a
really big limitation of writing apps so
there's this idea where you write apps
that are that work offline by taking
offline into consideration from the very
beginning and what where that really
leads to it's basically just writing a
full local app so the entire apps code
and the entire and all your data is
completely local that's really what it
leads to you because to work on flying
and to boot it up offline you kind of
just have to do that so it's a complete
reaaahhr texture I personally I actually
like the term local first apps better so
the main problem why I think they
haven't taken off is because syncing is
very very hard and if you are a full
local app you have to deal with syncing
where if you have these apps across
devices then you have to sync your data
across the devices and turns out this is
actually super super hard you cannot
just queue up changes into an array when
you were offline and then when you come
back on online push them out to the
server that does not work so a lot of
local apps they say that they have
offline support but you always end up
running into these situations you're
doing stuff offline and then suddenly
this big red scary box comes up and says
attempting to restore a connection
changes me now may not be saved I mean
come on why don't you just tell me they
won't be saved ok so let's take a step
back the first thing we need to do is we
have to admit that local apps they are a
distributed system there's no way around
that we have multiple Verte we have
multiple instances of your app on
different devices and they can go off
and do their thing and then they need to
come back and sync up that is a
distributed system and distribute
systems are very hard to get right so I
am James long I did I did create
prettier a lot of other people helped
push it to mainstream so I'm very
grateful for those these people are
recently I've been working on an app
called actual it's a personal finance
app
you can go to actual budget calm if you
want to check it out this is a full
local app but it seamlessly syncs across
devices so when I started actual these
were my requirements these were the
features that I wanted were to really
have it had to be available offline and
it had to be fast turns out when all of
your data is local and it's just there
all the time you just end up getting a
super fast without much work focus on
privacy also one of the ability to
provide arbitrary queries all of this
let led me to just build a local app
that felt way better than building a
normal web app so here's an example of
doing arbitrary queries this feature is
not actually released yet but if you
have a couple years or you know just
just a little bit of your financial data
you can come in here and create a custom
report and it has like a [ __ ] DB ish
style syntax that just compiles down to
a sequel Lite query I'm essentially
exposing a sequel Lite directly to you
you would never ever do this if you were
writing a cloud-based app you would
never imagine taking arbitrary code and
executing on executing it on your server
right this is a reason why you don't do
that there's a reason why graph QL
doesn't even have a simple aggregate
function like some because all your data
is local sure you can see quite inject
yourself as much as you want whatever so
I realized though I need a mobile app
because you really do need to have your
transactions on the go so I was like
crap I need to figure out syncing so
this led me down a whole path of you
know building a sync engine pretty much
for better for worse I stopped on your
product and I built my instinct engine
but I did launch my product so at least
there's that
so that here's an example you can fill
in some budget values on one client of
course you can sync between desktop apps
to you so the second one syncs and it
got this budget values it adds another
one and then this one also it deletes a
category and then when the other one
syncs up so you can merge categories and
do all this complicated stuff the other
one syncs up and it has exactly the same
state so he these were my my use cases I
have very simple data we're talking
about a five to ten megabytes equal a
database we're not building a back-end
database that has to deal with a
terabyte of data this is a whole
different world also I had to have
syncing on top of sequel Lite I was not
willing to switch databases so if you
have to if you wanted to use
a couple of the other solutions out
there they require you to just trust
them to take your data I did not want to
give up sequel it gives me sub
sub-millisecond read queries which is
absolutely amazing it's a whole reason
why the app is fast so I was not willing
to give up sequel Lite this thinking has
to be a layer on top of it to this day I
still understand why everything is so
bundled together okay so why is thinking
so hard there are two main problems
unreliable ordering and conflicts
whatever we do here whatever we do to
solve this it has to work a hundred
percent of the time this has to be
seamless there can not be never note no
data loss or no state of the app that
gets into a case where it doesn't work
because remember this is a local lab you
can't just refresh the tab I'm accepting
the responsibility that this is gonna
work the hundred percent of the time so
let's talk about unreliable ordering so
say you have two devices or two clients
and they do changes over time let's just
say that they are you know making
setting properties of an object we want
to think about this as if it's one
timeline right that there's a sequential
order of events the problem is though
that we are distributed we have two apps
that are doing two four things at
different times and when they try to
sync up they are going to receive the
changes at different times so B does not
get a's changes directly when they
happen it's not like quantum computing
or something like that and so as the
changes are propagated seem to back and
forth between the devices it's gonna get
them in different order and so we can't
just naively mutate our data as we are
seeing changes otherwise the first the
first client would would apply a C D and
B if you can read that and then the
second client would apply B ad and C so
obviously we can't do out of order
mutations because the resulting state is
going to be different so back-end apps
or back in databases they do they have
this thing called strong consistency and
this requires a lot of coordination and
it's actually really complex and a lot
of them actually don't actually get it
right a recent trend is to do eventual
consistency and this is a technique
where you embrace the fact that there
are multiple timelines you embrace the
fact that you are a distributed system
you admit that and then you find
solutions
mesh well with that instead of trying to
go against that so the idea here is is
there a way to where even if we get the
changes in in different order is there a
way that we can still produce the state
the same state on each device so this is
the problem if we can solve this and we
have eventual consistency as long as
every single client has seen the changes
the same changes even that even if
they're out of order then they will have
the same state so that is our goal that
is what we want to achieve so how do we
solve unreliable ordering and we need to
assign timestamps this is the first
thing that that we that we need to do to
do this we can go back to Einstein time
is relative
it's only net worth depends on upon what
we do as it is passing so we don't need
like a date now timestamp obviously
there's a clock so horrible when we
can't actually rely on data now what we
want is just some order of events so we
just want some relative order where when
the change happens here what changes has
that device already seeing that's what
we really want so you could think of you
know if it's just a suit like a sequence
ID one two three four but we obviously
can't do this because this would rely on
some sort of global sequence ID and
requires strong consistency and we we
just can't do that we need a we need a
way to do this per per device so to do
that you need a clock and you need a
special kind of clock so there's a
couple different types of clocks like a
vector clock fortunately I don't
unfortunately I don't have time to
actually explain how these clocks work
but there's a vector clock there's
another kind of clock called a hybrid
logical clock which is HLC this is the
kind of clock that I use it's a super
interesting clock and what these clocks
do is they exist per device this is not
something that exists on some local or
like on some centralized server that
everybody tries to coordinate with these
are per device clocks what they do is
they generate time stamps that we can
assign to each change so for example
this is what HLC is look like hoc s are
super cool because they can be see
realized too in just a normal string
again this the times that can be any
value the vector clock is actually like
a vector of like
multiple entries and stuff like that all
that we care about is when you assign
when you assign a timestamp to it change
the clock is smart enough to give us us
being the ephemeral like whoever is
trying to sync some data so that we can
compare changes and say did this change
when it happened on this machine
did it come after all of these other
things that the machine has already seen
right so it's just a relative ordering
so this is an example there's two
changes set X to three has a timestamp
set X to five set X set X to 3 has a
later time stamp so the HLC provided
this timestamp for us and so if we were
doing like elastomeric wins then setting
X 2 3 would win in this case if you were
applying both these changes so don't
don't get tripped up by the fact that it
looks like were you actually using like
a real date like you see a real dating
here hyper logical clocks there's a
whole paper written about the algorithm
it's super interesting and I don't have
time to fully explain it right now but
just trust that we have this string that
we can say is the string less than this
other string then that's the timestamp
became before that string and that's
what hoc is enable you to do now Dykstra
said simplicity is a prerequisite for
for reliability this is a complex
problem just distributed apps and
distribute systems is a complex problem
and the way to have it reliable is to
have a simple solution complex problems
do not necessarily beget complex
solutions we want this to be super
reliable 100% reliable in the face of
terrible networks in the face of you
putting your phone down for two weeks
picking it back up and then it syncs all
these complicated changes right it has
to work one percent of the time for this
to happen we have to have the least
amount of code possible and that is what
is so good about hybrid logical clocks
this is the entire implementation of
harbor logical clocks zero dependencies
here
it's 256 lines of lines of lines and
JavaScript right how cool is that I mean
it seems like you could sit down and
learn that in like a weekend right I
feel like that a lot of times as
developers we over complicate things we
try to take on too much of the problem
let's try to distill things down into a
single problem and solve that
256 lines of JavaScript with no
dependencies because dependencies suck
alright so we've solved C we've solved
sort of solve the ordering problem so
what about conflicts there's nothing
around the fact that two devices can go
offline set the same piece of data and
then come back off and then come back
online so we haven't magically solved
that somehow well what do existing
solutions do they say well you got a
right manual conflict resolution code
right and the only response to that my
opinion is you know did you just
suddenly go screw myself I mean I
believe I did Bob because really may no
convict resolution does not work it's
basically just issuing one of the
hardest parts of this whole thing on to
you and as a developer you are not gonna
write correct manual conflict resolvers
I'm not going to and I think I'm smart
there's just too hard there's way too
many edge cases to resolve conflicts and
conflicts dealing with conflicts it's
something you need to be thinking about
while you are structuring and shaping
your data it's not a post-processing
step it's not a post step that after
everything syncs up and then you resolve
the conflicts so the question is how do
we resolve conflicts then there is an
answer to this this is a magical thing
called CRD T's okay okay I know what
you're thinking we're not gonna get into
any math we're not gonna do any complex
stuff it's really not as hard as it
seems all it is is a partially ordered
ma annoyed in the category of endo
functors Oh with at least with at least
upper bound so it's a semi lattice
essentially no but really seriously 3d
T's I'm just going to pick out the
important parts for you the parts that
you need to build production apps it's
actually only a little bit of all of
that theory so steer D T stands for
conflict free replicated data types you
may if you're familiar with this world
you may have seen all of these terms
these are just implementations of ceará
cuties so CR DT is just more of a broad
term there's no canonical implementation
of them all that it is you don't have to
worry about these at all all that they
are are data structures that have
certain properties to properties to be
exact
what is that they're commutative which
means the order doesn't matter in which
you apply the changes the second is that
they're idempotent which means it
doesn't matter how many times you apply
that change
think about that for a second if it
doesn't matter what order you apply
changes and doesn't matter how many
times you apply the change you can
essentially just throw changes over the
wall and if this date is not what you
think it should be then you just throw
some more changes
I mean it's essentially a superpower
right super reliable in the face of a
crappy network or a distributed system
so let's just go through and look at
what it would be to implement a CR DT
let's say that we have this set of
changes X X set X to 300 and so we fill
out the process we're just going to fill
out this this object with with with
values as we apply these messages or
these changes so it set X to 300 set Y
to 73 set X to 8 but wait setting X 8
didn't do anything and that's because
the timestamp is older right so that x
thing the timestamp is a key part of
this because that's what enables this
commutative and idempotent properties of
these production-ready CR DT so I mean
you could use here DTS in all sorts of
ways but these are the ones that all you
need to build production apps and then
we assign Z to 114 so this is the
resulting state x y&z with these numbers
we could do this in any order so set X
to eight set Y to 73 so here X does
equal eight but it's because it hasn't
seen this other message yet so set X to
300 that timestamp is later and so now
it actually does apply that message
congratulations you just implemented
your first CDT this is the last right
winds map this is basically just a set
of messages that when you apply them
through and get this object out you you
have a last write winds map this is now
distributed you could sync these changes
across devices so you have a map which
is a basic building block for building a
an app right let's just replace that map
with an L W map the only other thing you
really need is a set so a map is just
like an item like a to-do item and a set
is a collection of items right so those
are kind of the building blocks of
relapse for a set we can replace it with
what's called a grow only set a G set so
in example that would be you have a
bunch of messages there are two
duplicate IDs here so adding the same ID
to the same set it doesn't do anything
and the result is this set
no it's aggro only set you can never
remove something from a set so when
something is distributed
you can never safely remove anything
right because you might get changes that
actually change that object but if
you've already actually removed it from
your local data then that's a problem so
you just never remove it okay so this is
a G set okay so how do I make basic
relational data into CRD keys we have
everything that we need to solve this so
remember I have this sequel Lite
database that I want to turn that I want
to treat as CEO DT is how do i implement
this well the answer is I can treat a
sequel light table as a G set of lww
Maps and so to implement this I have
just one new table in my sequel I'd
database it's called the messages ERD T
table and this basically just saved all
of the messages that I have ever seen
whether I generated then myself or I got
them from other devices it has a
timestamp it has a data set which is
such at the table that it applies to has
a row which is the item ID has a column
and then and then the value so as these
messages are trickling in it just think
of it as like selecting a cell in the
sequel light table and putting a value
right there if the timestamp is greater
than whatever value was there before
that's it
that's all I do and I've built my entire
app on that note it's important to note
that if the item does not exist yet like
if there's no row for that ID it just
creates it and then it puts that one
value in that field so it just sort of
trickles down gradually expands and I've
built my entire app on this so how does
it actually look like while programming
so I have a function so I can do raw
sequel queries to read my data right
that's the important part that's what I
really wanted in the first place I can
have super fast read queries but to
change the data it's a little different
I have a couple of functions like update
which just takes the table the ID and
then some fields and it just generates
the messages to push through the system
so to change my local data it's exactly
the same way as syncing when I get
messages from other people it syncs it
through it pushes it through the syncing
layer but I change stuff myself I just
call update generates the messages and
it pushes it through the second layer
it's all the exact same thing so how do
you delete stuff will have a delete
function which takes a table and
and this generates a message which
changes the tombstone field so it can
never remove something from this set
everything just has a tombstone field
and I just set that value to 1 and then
I just ignore those whenever I'm reading
from them so other features but I don't
have time to time to talk about you can
ensure consistency with a Merkel tree
Merkel tree is a tree of hashes that
represents all the time stands that time
stamps that have been applied that gives
us something to compare across clients
you can do end-to-end encryption here so
I really like I can host this like a
Bennett like a like a singing server so
just a very short quick demo I built
this demo app you can see that Ike I'm
offline I've killed the server I can add
stuff and I'm gonna add an item with a
different category and then and then I'm
gonna delete that category on the other
client so what's gonna happen here it's
gonna sink that date that category it's
gonna sink that item with a different
category so what should that first
client have well I've mapped that
category onto personal so once I've seen
it a couple of times it eventually
catches up and everything maps to
personal so you you when you're
structuring your data I can't go into
all of the techniques for doing this but
you think about conflicts so that you
just bypass them altogether and that
there doesn't exist a conflict that I
have a table that map's the the
categories automatically and I shape my
data so that continent conflicts can't
even ever occur so that's sort of the
additional layer again super simple this
is the client-side implementation of the
entire syncing layer and all of the
database to one or 50 lines JavaScript
so for all of this if you go to my
sample get github repo you can see the
entire implementation of all of this 132
lines of JavaScript on a server
it just gets messages sends them back
the client is 630 lines of JavaScript
this is pretty much all of the code that
I use in actual to build the entire
syncing layer and I've had really no
problems with it it's 65 tweets how long
does it take you to tweet 65 times
probably in bed tweet like 20 times so
it's like three nights so the only
dependency is that it has our UUID in
murmur hash right you're not I'm not
shoving
garbage into the closet and then it's
actually you're pulling in like a 150
megabyte dependency like Chris Harmon
said yesterday this is the real code
okay so
apps have a very very superior user
experience and I really want to
encourage people to look into this more
and anybody who's working on this I
really encourage you to look into CRT
T's and some simple methods to implement
clocks we've got to start simplifying
our solutions and not take on so much
code which come which come like makes
things more complex thank you
[Applause]
[Music]